hi there everyone as some of you might
know we're just back from New York where
we attended the 16th annual Webby Awards
amazingly we were one of the winners now
at the webby awards everyone whether
they're famous or a bit more obscure
like us is limited to a 5 word speech
and here's the one we made thorium
helium thallium thank you
now I know that was over pretty quickly
so here it is again as filmed by me with
my nerdy little camera
thorium fool iam thallium thank you now
we did a few other bits and pieces while
we're in New York and hopefully you
might see them in some upcoming videos
but in the meantime I recommend you have
a look at another channel of mine called
numberphile all about mathematics and
numbers because our latest video also
has been of an American twist it's all
about billions and trillions and who
gets it right and who gets it wrong all
right rubbish they everyone started to
do it it makes no sense at least I can't
see the sense in it and we'll be back
here on periodic videos very soon with
more chemistry including an experiment
by the professor he is a bit of a snake
Pig
so this is actually much better than I
intended